[Musique]
moments d'insouciance arraché à la
tragédie de bien belles images mises à
la disposition par l'armée américaine
pour redorer un peu son blason elles
contrastent avec les scènes de chaos qui
continue de se dérouler à quelques pas
de là immergé jusqu'aux genoux dans un
égout aux allures de douves ces afghans
font le siège de l'aéroport de kaboul le
long de l'enceinte ils sont des milliers
à vouloir fuir être emmenés par les
soldats américains et occidentaux chargé
de trier la misère brusques montées
d'angoissé
après la confirmation du retrait des
états unis le 31 août
les 6000 soldats américains ne
sécuriseront plus ni l'aéroport ni les
évacuations joe biden l'a finalement
confirmé du tonneau pour en finir mieux
ce sera chaque jour d'opération apporte
un risque supplémentaire pour nos
troupes ces images qui en disent long
sur les réelles intentions des talibans
on y voit des devantures de magasins de
beauté de kaboul sur lesquels les
visages de femmes ont été maculés de
peinture pour effacer leur trailer
cheveux sous leurs yeux dans les rues de
la capitale se sont toutes les
représentations de la femme qui
disparaissent peu à peu
oui oui
non
avec un sens du show bien à elle ses
lutteuses en jupon met en avant tous les
travers de la société bolivienne le
machisme et la violence faite aux femmes
arnaud le thé le nom désignant la queue
de la robe de mariée
la traînée au nom non elle est mariée
seulement c'est la traîne
jamais de ma vie sont la vaisselle il
est beau et robuste l'écart et cherche
bien charpenté comme on aime dont les
femmes économique
de péniches est un ustensile comme celui
ci toutes les femmes en rêve en fait
[Musique]
le
nous les jetons
après des siècles de discrimination
sociale la tchaux litas du 21e siècle
est une femme forte qu'on se le dise il
est voulu et il se met au lit
et du café de
catherine le elle
avait mis quoi dans le café aujourd'hui
il ya un truc bizarre ou
chantal bonjour bonjour
ça va saint max voilà le slogan trouvé
par le ministère de la santé en
partenariat avec skyrock pour encourager
les ados à se faire vacciner contre le
coni
et un maxi bus sillonnera la france à
partir de la mi septembre en découvrant
cette campagne cet internaute a ressenti
une gêne kim ans elle a trouvé cela
ringard ils sont nombreux dans ce cas là
a moqué à part les djeuns caricatural
pensé par des boumeurs
donc voilà bah voilà toujours on fait
rien on nomme et non mais non rien mais
il est pas là pour te donner des idées à
l'écrit pas comme ça qu'on colle pages
ont
été lues en 2017 avec des idées
révolution c'était livre du bouquin de
maquereaux il a été élu avec des idées
pour redresser il allait tour de rester
là on est à la fin du quinquennat c'est
pas le moment de venir nous donner des
idées le chiffre du jour c'est avec vous
et manuel
sur le même et chaque jour et
aujourd'hui c'est un âge 55 ans oui 55
ans c'est l'âge auquel les jeunes
français souhaiterait prendre leur
retraite c'est le résultat d'une étude
devenez à l'échelle de toute l'europe
par le cabinet rh sd worx et personne ne
souhaite en europe partir plus tôt que
les français les jeunes on est plus
pressé de prendre notre tournée les plus
pressés combien de bougies la reine
elizabeth ii at elle soufflé cette année
cette bonne vieille queen elizabeth
[Musique]
mal est fait en tout cas on ne sont
les jeunes néerlandais a eu ses 60 ans
mais attention parce qu'on pose aussi la
question aux plus de 55 ans et les plus
de 55 ans ils disent nous on veut partir
à 62 ans et là encore en europe il ya
personne qui souhaite partir plus tôt
puisque les belges ses 63 ans les
anglais les allemands 65 ans et les
néerlandais 66 ans la photo est devenue
culte tout comme l'album vous la
connaissez ce bébé nu dans l'eau c'est
la pochette de nevermind de nirvana et
bien aujourd'hui 30 ans après spencer
elden le bébé de la photo porte plainte
pour pornographie infantile ils
réclament 130000 euros à chaque personne
ayant organisé la prise de vue et des
dommages et intérêts à l'époque son père
avait touché 200 dollars justin voisine
question malaisie j'ai donc il ya une
association qui réellement milite pour
l'accouchement à domicile oui alors
justement
vraiment rien d'autre à [ __ ] de leur
vie que
vous avez bien accueilli notre invité là
donc isabelle chronique est avec vous
serez donc
son maire de poids au travail situés un
peu de temps tu peux être zèbre le temps
d'une journée
seulement une journée
pour entrer dans la famille des zèbres
je vais devoir suivre une petite
formation sans mesurer que j'y perdrais
une part de ma dignité alem en amour un
commencement des jo larqué à l'envers
comme à poigne et toi j'ai trop aimé
dans l'encoche dans le cercle c'est quoi
une encoche alors amour amour amour sur
la 1000 voix l'amour sur la ville
bonjour et voilà aulas vous remet un
petit bonjour
oméga amour sur la base un amour amour
partout où elle vit à ça passe ou là ou
là
en voyant ces images beaucoup
d'internautes ont pensé dinosaures
diplodocus et brachiosaures
et à cette scène du film jurassic park
[Musique]
la vérité derrière cette vidéo à plus
d'un million de vues est moins
surprenante quoique il s'agit d'une pale
d'éolienne transporté sur un camion en
chine il est 6 heures